hi my name is mark it's been a while but
now you know about in space with
markiplier which is the project that
i've been filming in the sequel to a
heist with markiplier also i've been
very paranoid about not telling you
about in space with markiplier for two
damn years which is why i've been saying
heist with markiplier 2 or heist 2 or
the sequel to a heist with markiplier so
explicitly and if you've ever watched me
say it you've noticed that there's been
a twitch in my eye because i've been so
afraid of telling you what it is but now
you know all about it and i'm almost
done filming we actually have a week
left and that's why videos have been
very sparse is because
not only is it um is this project bigger
than heist was
by a lot but also it's much more
complicated
by a lot but one week left to filming
and then post-production but video
should be able to get back on track
relatively soon gonna try that is uh not
only did lixian have a baby which big
congratulations to lixian but also
rachel and marcus are on vacation so
it's just me at the moment which is
totally fine i've done this before i'm a
professional youtuber i know how to edit
i'm editing this right now i bet
i am editing it unless i just left it
raw and uploaded it straight up like
this which is a possibility but also i'd
like to i'm opting to cut this part out
not because i said anything terrible but
because i personally requested it to
myself right here god i hope i edit this
out and there you have it
i'd like to publicly shame a person
which is exactly the point of this
channel i am the premier youtube public
shaming channel as we all know and i
would like to publicly shame one wade
barnes also known as the drowned man
i i wanna shame him because i've been
keeping this secret about in space with
markiplier about how we were going to
space in the sequel for almost two years
now and the day after the day after
heist comes out and i talked to wade i
was like oh yeah the sequel is going to
be in space but don't tell anybody about
that he thought i was joking so this
this man
this man this guy
he tweeted at me after i was like man
such a good thing we did on heist is so
fun i'm so happy everyone got to see all
the hard work it's so great he tweeted
tweet replied me he replied two at me
with twitter he said
next time we're going to space you told
me so you promised
just out in the blue and i have to text
him frantically like what the hell man
you are such a douchebag delete that and
he thought i was joking he thought
surely i could not be going actually to
space or making a space show so he
thought i was joking so he made that
tweet as if it was just a big joke and
there we were a day after heist came out
and he spoils it all but no one caught
on and he deleted it so ha
that's what you get for not being
observant but now the cat's out of the
bag and the show will be coming out very
soon well not very soon relatively soon
coming soon with a trademark at the end
of it because nobody knows when that
exactly is but actually i do know
exactly when that is but i'm not going
to tell you but it's not very soon it's
just soonish once that's done though
um i'm uh i'm gonna go home once this is
all done i'm gonna go home and i'm going
to uh make youtube videos and i'm going
to focus on youtube which is you know
my main job and admittedly i'm doing
this show for my youtube channel and
this is going to be posted on my channel
for free for anybody uh and i love
making it but also just like
i miss making kind of dumb videos that
aren't exactly high production quality i
do love this one though oh you guys are
gonna love this one i i literally
oh god i like i talked to everybody
that's been on it to amy i'm just like
oh man
they don't deserve this
they don't deserve you don't deserve it
but you are going to freaking love it
you're going to get it doesn't matter if
you deserve it or not you're going to
get it and just like
oh um i can't wait for you to see it
it's oh
so happy i'm very very happy with her
it's oh it's coming along it's not even
done yet we're not even done filming it
something horrible could go wrong with
the production so i guess i shouldn't
get ahead of myself but can't wait for
you guys to see it so i'm gonna get back
to it i gotta record a lot of videos and
i gotta add the videos i gotta figure
out how to edit again
uh it's been a while
i can do it
thank you everybody so much i can't wait
for oh
it's such a dream to be able to do these
things
just
ah it's so nice
and all the crew have been great and the
production has been great and
everything's been going great and you
know
no it's just it's a dream
i love it can't wait for you to see it
so i'm gonna leave now okay all right
get out bye see you bye leave doors
right there door's right there that's
close